في موسيقى صباح عندنا اليوم معانا فنان
رومانسي غامر في التلحين وحقق نجاحات في
الاغنيات اللي غناها
مشاهدينا تميز باللون الخليجي وتحديدا
السعوديه العزاوي ومن خلال اغنيه تاخذ
العقل ضرب رقم قياسي عالي تعددت مشاهدات
الاغنيه هذه اثنين وخمسين مليون مشاهده
ايضا مشاهدينا بتلحينه اغنيه ولا غلطه
التي حققت 44 مليون مشاهده ايضا على
اليوتيوب
[موسيقى]
سعادتو مهما بك حكيت حتمه من قبلك ترى كل
هالليل توها تضوي بعيني يومين طيب عبد
الرحمن يعني اغنيه او اغنيتين على الاقل
حققوا هذا النجاح الهائل وعدد مشاهدات
مهول على اليوتيوب خلينا نبدا باغنيه تاخذ
العقل
ليش باللهجه السعوديه او اللهجه الخليجيه
مش بلهجتك المحليه اللهجه العراقيه
اول شيء نصبح عليكم على الساده المشاهدين
اختيار اللهجه الخليجيه كان عندي اعمالنا
عراقيه سابقا كوني عراقي يعني فحبيت اني
اغير وادخل مجال اخر يعني فكان في اتفاق
مع الشعر ليبدا بالغنتين هم وباقي الاعمال
ايضا وكان معاي الموزم الاماراتي محمد
الجسمي فصارت خلطه سعوديه اماراتيه عراقيه
فطلعت بهذا الجمال
يمكن دائما هذه اختلاف الاذواق واختلاف
المشارب تعطيك شيء جديد انعكس هذا الشيء
على اغانيك عبد الرحمن طبعا اليوم السنجل
تغني عن البوم طبعا ومن مرات البوم يعني
يتكون من عشرات الاغاني في العشرين اغنيه
مثلا اغنيه وعشر اغاني ما تنجح فقط اغنيه
وحده يغنيك عن البوم كامل
ليش ليش النجاح للاغنيه الواحده انت تحتاج
اصلا لانك تحتاج اغنيه وحده فقط هي تنجح
فتكون كفيله انه هي توصل للناس وتجدد
وجودك مع الجمهور احنا حابين نسمع منك شي
بس قبل هيك كنت حابه بس اسالك طيب ايش
معنى ليش برايك اغنيه تاخذ العقل قدرت
انها تحقق 52 مليون مشاهده هذا رقم مهول
على اليوتيوب ايش معنى مع انها برضو يعني
اغنيه مش بطيئه ولك وايضا ليست سريعه يعني
ايقاعها مش ايقاع رقص هدول الاغاني اللي
دائما بيحضروا بكثير متابعات والله هي
شوفي اول شيء اول شيء توفيق من رب
العالمين هذه اول نقطه يعني ثانيا جهود
الكادر العمل يعني شاعر والموزع وايضا
كانوا لهم سبب في النجاح ثالثا الغناء كان
باحساس عالي
كان بحب العمل كان بحب وصل للناس بحب وحبه
يعني
سمعكم الاغنيه يلا
عن عيون الناس ودي يمنعك حتى صوتك بس انا
اللي يسمعك تاخذ العقل بجمالك تاخذ غيري
لو شافك يا خوفي يتبعك لك شعوري قبل عيني
ابتسم ينهزم حزني قربك ينهزم انت ما خليت
فرصه للعتب تدري لينا الحين احس اني بحلم
حبيبي
انت حبيبي